hello everyone and welcome back to the
1921 World Chess Championship match
between Emanuele Alaska and josé raúl
capablanca this is game number ten so
far Capablanca won one game all the
other games ended in a draw so it's
after Lasker to get back into the match
here Alaska has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 let's just dive straight
into it with d5 by capablanca and of
course we are going into the Queens
gambit declined with Knight c3 Knight to
f6 and Bishop to g5 with Bishop to e7
again laughter now first developed the
dark square bishop only then finishes
the pawn chain with castles by
capablanca and Knight to f3 Knight B to
d7 continuing development Alaska goes
for Queen c2 the Rubinstein variation
preparing Bishop to b3 to put pressure
on the h7 square with c5 by capablanca
and now rook to d1 so obviously last one
will not be castling queenside with
Queen to a5 now painting the knight and
the Bishop to d3 as planned so last pro
of course does not enjoy this tension
here he pushes h6 makes sure the h7
ponies in never a target anymore Bishop
to h4 of course last but not interested
in giving up the bishop pair and now see
captures on d4 with it captures and now
D captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4
and now night to be six hour even
averting the Knights a better Square
from there the knight can come to d5 but
for the moment Alaska has to deal with
the bishop on c4 so Bishop to b3
Bishop to d7 and here our last pair
catches a moment of breath and he
decides the castle before this Bishop
you know maybe
prevents him from castling with King to
g1 and now rook a to c8 Bishop to b5
still an idea as the rook now occupies
the same file as the Queen with nice the
e5 by Lasker and just improving the
position of the night and Bishop to b5
now the knight is pinned so you cannot
capture the rook is under attack so
rooked ft-1 and now Knight d5 a very
interesting move back up a Blanca which
last pair does not
not well I'm not gonna say punished but
Lasker could have played a better move
here here Lasker played Bishop capture
son b5 which a lot of copper blanc had
to really just trade it down but he had
a better more so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out this
improvement in the position both last
foreign kappa blanka missed it's not a
simple idea
so in only if you want to I'll give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
have just found a movable a spur and
capablanca missed and for those who want
to enjoyed it just one enjoy the show
Bishop captures on f6 it's a bit of an
improvement because here you cannot
capture with the night you have to
capture with the bishop and then you get
Bishop captures on d5 but then it's
different because then he captures and
d5 comes and the epon will become the
deep one will become a weak point the
problem is if Knight captures on f6 then
the idea is Knight to g6 and here just
everything can go wrong for black well
first of all first of all you are gonna
lose the root kind of fate there's no
good way to save the rook if you play
something like rook e8
then you get the rook captures on e6 and
this is just disgusting
if you captured the knight then you open
up this diagonal from the bishop to the
King then something like rookie six
check and pick up the Queen if you
captured the rook then it's even worse
it's mating for Bishop captures with
check King to h7 now comes the knight to
f8 the double check from the knight and
the Queen King to h8 and now everyone's
favorite smothered mate quint h7 check
captures and 96 mate so one of the
things that can happen after Knight to G
says but also if you just captured the
knight Bishop captures with check just
picks up the rookin c8 and the bishop on
e7 is still undefended so here for
example after King to h7 you can capture
it black recaptures you get rook
captures on e7 and the black is just
falling apart you are just just winning
here so a slight improvement in the
position definitely Bishop captures on
f6 but okay last prevent for Bishop
captures on d5 with Knight captures on
d5 and here we have a nice series of
trades captures capture 77 and Queen to
b3 now with a double attack on the
bishop so here kappa blanka goes Knight
bishop
see 6 he says he doesn't like Bishop to
a6 because of Knight d7 to c5 could be
somewhat unpleasant so instead he goes
Knight Bishop to c6 last Pro of course
is very happy to get rid of this monster
Bishop with Knight captures B captures
and now rook to e5 wouldn't that would
an attack against Kappa Blancas Queen
Queen to b6 capablanca offers a trade
also hopes that last group will capture
so he can improve the position the
structure of his pawns but last of
course declines Queen to c2 still
keeping you know all the chances alive
he can get some maybe very nice
maneuvering and with Knight to e4 maybe
at the d6 maybe even to f6 if the Queen
can get over to the over to the Queen
King side rook F to d8 now with a double
attack against the d4 pawn and here you
see workup Blanca is going with the
position the material is equal even both
players have three pawn islands the
problem is Lasker's isolated the D pawn
is much more of a weakness than
capablanca isolated a 7-point it's much
harder for Alaska to attack the a7 pond
than it is for a couple of lanka to
attack the d4 point and this is where
what couple blanca will use to try and
push for more than a draw here here at
last group goes Knight to e2 he wants to
create a very nice defensive setup as
the d4 pawn will become a target kappa
blanka doesn't like this he says Knight
to a4 with an attack on the Queen
followed by rook the c5 sort of creating
a counter-attack against the c6 pawn
could have been better for Lasker but
you know so it's a matter of choice
so Knight to e2 and now rook to d5
Capablanca offers a rook trade we have
rook captures
C captures now opening up an attack
against the Queen here also fixing his
pawn structure with Queen to d2 and now
comes Knight to f5 so here you can see
that the d4 point is a huge liability
now and last but will have to waste a
lot of time defending it
so first b3 if you don't want the b2
pond to remain a target for the rest of
the game and the Queen that will have to
defend it you have to play b3
we have h5 by capablanca he doesn't want
to allow g4 the knight on f5 is really
great
the only way to get rid of it is h3g for
you don't have the epon to get rid of it
this way but even if you did still the
d5 own defenses so this is a well this
is basically a monster night here and it
will give lasts for a very hard time
with h3 preparing g4 but capablanca
prevents it with h4 no more pawn moves
on the King side at least while the
Queen's are on the board you don't want
to play g4 here and allow H captures g3
on poisson while the Queen's are still
on the board so Queen to d3 last we're
just waiting to see what capablanca will
do and now rook the c6 and okay we have
King to f1 and now comes g6 capablanca
makes room for his king to enter the
game with Queen to b1 still just waiting
to see what happens Queen to b4 and now
pink the g1 this is the last Perseid
move this is move thirty-one as you know
the time control is 15 moves per hour
this is more 30 now Kings you want is
move 31 I'll ask her seal this move and
after the game continue come up Marcus's
it's not the the greatest of moves even
though it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine but it doesn't
do anything for white but that's exactly
where white needs to do in this position
for example if you seal the move that
was forcing or something of course
Capablanca would help analyze that at
home and then you know found any any
sort of possible replication to do such
a move
so Kings you want is the is the best
idea here with a five-way capablanca
going for a four he wants to create
weaknesses on the Queen side that he can
attack Queen to be tube just waiting to
see what happens and a four Queen to d2
last pair now offers a queen trait so he
can at least start something like g4
capablanca says okay no problem Queen
captures rook captures and mount it
captures on b3 with a capture Sun b3 and
now look the b6 just forcing rook to d3
look the b2 yes you always want to put a
rope behind the pass pawn but here the
rook to be too the problem is rook to b4
and you cannot keep an eye on both your
b3 point F and your d4 point so here
Luke d3 is forced and now this leaves
capablanca the option of going rogue to
a 6 and now infiltrating with the
finally the Queen's er of the board so
Lasker can bougie for the night away
from such a wonderful square with H
captors and g3 I'm Poisson FK person g3
now preparing g4 and Luke 2:8 you now
first attacking last night with Knight
to c3 attacking the rook and now rook
the sea to first putting pressure on the
night we have Knight back to D 1 and now
Knight 37 knock off a bottle or even
over this night to a much better square
the idea is knight c6 285 and pick up
the b3 pawn after of course the rook
gets behind the past pawn so we have
Knights - III attacking the rook rook
the c1 check with King - f2 and mountain
Knight to c6
we have knife to d1 and now rook to be 1
now Capablanca has his rook behind the
passed pawn which is great the thread is
Knights 285 and he will pick up this B
to report there is nothing last we can
do about it so hence last person next
move king te - Micah mentions it's not a
blunder or anything it's just that you
can't defend the b3 pawn so feel free to
pause the video here and tell me what
what do you play here with black well I
give you a couple of seconds I know all
of you found it so congratulations to
everyone who found it and also of course
URI I can only imagine enjoying the show
but not Knight 95 here route captors and
v3 is just much faster because here is
last portrayed and then you get Knight
captures here with Czech you pick up
another pawn you pick up the rook and
then it's 4 points against 2 points of
course completely winning 4 Capablanca
so after route capture son b3 with king
- III just improving the position of the
king and now look the b4 still a couple
longer says I'm up a pawn now I'm gonna
keep pressuring your d4 pawn and you're
gonna have to use at least two pieces to
defend it or a king and the piece while
I improve the position of my own King
and then I'm gonna start pushing so
Knight to c3 by Lasker we have Knight to
e7 by Capablanca Knight to e2 just Rema
nuvaring and Knight to f5 check
pressuring the g3 pawn and the d4 pawn
from f5 with King to f2 now defending
the pawn hand also preparing to push g4
and g5 by Capablanca with g4 pushing the
knight back nice
thirty-six and now Knight to g1 and here
Knight to e4 with check so an excellent
score for tonight it's very unlikely
that white will be able to kick the
right away from their King to f1 and now
rook the b1 check my kappa blanka King
to g1 and now Ruby to check King f1 and
now rook the F to check with King t1 and
now tree maneuvering to recover to a -
threatening rook e1 check the key to
pick up the night as the dark knight is
covering the f2 squared
soaking back to f1 and now finally
capablanca enters the last phase of the
game improved the position of your own
King King g7 we've grouped the three
Lasker's without an active move he just
has to wait and see what a couple Blanca
will do King to g6 rook back to d3 and
here couple Blanca decides it's better
to bring the King over into the game
this way so we have f6 route back to III
by last for King to f7 route 2 D 3 and
kinked at E 7 route back to e3 Bell
asker and King to b6 now preparing e5
with rook to d3 by Lasker now first rook
F to check Capablanca includes this
little maneuver for who knows what
reason
King he won rook g2 now attacking the
knight King f1 attacking the rook and
rook back to a - now it's last move we
have rook to e3 and only now that the
rookies I need to recover Blanca pushes
the pawn with E 5 route back to d3
captures on d4 rook captures and finally
another King has a way to enter the game
King to c5 with rook to d1 and now all
that's left is to put the past pawn so
this is exactly what Capablanca does we
have d4 and what do you play here last /
played rope the c1 check Capablanca
played King to d5 and it was in this
position that Emmanuel Oscar resigned
the game on move 68 so game 10 goes to
Capablanca and he's now leading the game
by two points couple of course can still
get back into the match but it's very
hard as you know it's not that easy to
beat Capablanca although if you find
that Bishop characters and f6 idea that
was a slight improvement lasker could
have done this game but both of them
missed it well unfortunately for
Capablanca baton
for Lasker what he resigned well there's
just not stopping the pawn the king is
very passive he ran f-111 one such line
could be 92 let's say you just keep
pushing the pawn whatever white plays
you just keep pushing the pawn let's say
Ruby 1 you pinned the pawn but the d2o
whatever you play Kim Jiwan you're just
gonna play route k3 the three is rookie
three attack tonight after tonight moves
rook e1 one one possible way of winning
this
whatever white plays you don't have a
good move just gonna like I said Ruki
three maybe not c1 just the point can
I've captured due to the the pin but
still you just move the King for example
King to c4 or maybe just Luke II won
there's no defense here either white
will capture and then you get a queen
into the game or you can just capture
here and then you are done rook young
gustafson often says that the best the
best kind of endgame is where you have
rook and your opponent does not so here
is one one such example but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it it's
really really interesting how a couple
last pair really didn't make any
mistakes he just had a passive position
then maybe maybe Papa Blanca had
something there were when he said ninety
two was a bit too passive he was
defending the passive position from a
passive standpoint maybe ninety for a
4-fold by roof to see fog would have
been better but who knows the you know
the problem is he he allowed Capablanca
activity and capablanca used it and he
missed that little improvement that I'm
sure all of you saw all right with them
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank gr
sugar buck of Roy Branford Richard
pasamonte a Gary periode and Stuart
Graham for conclusion to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos so your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga checking
up on your suggestions which are always
lovely and checking up on what's new in
the world and of course as I'm currently
recording in this new setup I'm not in
my home town I mean I'm intro here at
the moment we'll be here for maybe five
to six days do sure if anything is wrong
with the audio the video or or anything
you can come up with
so think oh I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day